[Music]
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
not citizens you are terrible at this
your negative attitude is not helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
i have been called many names vengeance
the spikey supernovas but you may call
me
sorry
justice
here we go
hello
hedgehog
you're never going to get my power oh
contreramon
meet knuckles
i was expecting more of a fight
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the height
that wasn't too bad
seriously pretending to be batman blue
justice trademark pending
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is your moment to be the big hero
oh great the winter soldier
it is my destiny to destroy you work
smarter not harder
that wasn't too bad
the hedgehog 2 april 8th
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
forecast calls for a 100
chance of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
and here we go
get your heart out
papa's got a brand new stash
oh there's two of them now
you're never going to get my power
do i look like i need your power
sonic the hedgehog 2.
[Music]
bye